so with horse of all the multinational
saga nice book transfer hello benefits
very policy school so lucky you can I do
not believe else existed hermano
activity most of the firm's do pay taxes
fairly and by economic activity by
employment they are contributing to
prosperity of our society say massages
sank he perceived on April 1 clap
opposition initial a Commission European
today we propose a new partnership
framework for across-the-board
cooperation on migration with third
countries Jordan Lebanon Nisha
Nigeria Senegal Mali and Ethiopia this
could be done now not waiting for the
next boat to capsize remedy boost macht
das beste me arthritis 360 pilgrims
dolphin Africa see Fatah pink on a nice
toss n SD Amiga team in underside of
Antoine demos quest Oberon survey assay
giridhari certo ma survey sobre tu Toa
realizar un part radiata
politico-economic HEV LeCoultre r :
africa to say today oh we have the
solution for our problem we're gonna
simply duplicate the deal with turkey
are we gonna roll it out to all the
other countries sorry that is not the
way forward i think in the future it's
simply saying okay we give you money and
you keep the refugees legal migration
must not be done on the cheap and on the
quick we must do it properly so that we
have a proper mutual understanding with
the sending countries no cherry-picking
so far we have used twelve point eight
billion to infrastructure and innovation
window but also to SME financing
this twelve point eight billion is
expected to trigger
most private investment or
public-private partnership investments
in worth 100 billion people are calls
project a be a narcotic at me I invested
in the ticket Ali to come to Palm who
they recycle profile a whose rooms at
wash Martin Kaymer pardon instrument
Natalie that's consent androgynous
Marrakesh it's evolved a descender open
so bracket a mercenary relative or euro
robust I'll go see
Oh Tara Tara Neville still ruthless
companies' rankle mezzotints purchased a
total Megan revisited our ominous
elegant rottenest and our to Belarus
must certainly carry out all the
environmental impact assessments and
stress tests required by international
agreements SATA senior de prisa
Avellino Samia Tunisia new Lord is also
Mata Donna Schuurman
difficile kilovolt moon a passel Lahab a
debacle T we cannot convince the
Euroskeptics but we should mobilize the
pro Europeans all predictions for
failure and even this integration of the
European Union wrong are false we have
seen many crises in our history the cure
is clear more solidarity humanity and
empathy more rule of law most energies
more education more integration
you